[Music]
you've probably heard of dan cathy he's
a billionaire worth over eight billion
dollars and the
ceo of chick-fil-a he's controversial
making headlines for his anti-same-sex
marriage
stances and donating to anti-lgbtq plus
charities his father founded the company
and he took over
as ceo in 2013. although he's best known
for his involvement in chick-fil-a
he's also been pursuing production in
georgia
which has become a major center for film
and television
people were surprised that he was also
the money behind the biggest studio in
georgia and the second biggest studio in
the country
but after speaking to people familiar
with the deals and learning a little bit
more about dan kathy's own interests
it makes a lot of sense that this is the
path he's taking to establishing
something separate from chick-fil-a
george has become a major center for
film and television production ever
since they introduced tax incentives for
the industry in 2008.
about 2.7 billion dollars was spent by
the industry in the state into 2018
and even though there was a bit of a
pause during the pandemic
um they're expecting that number to hit
3 billion by 2022.
dan cathy's from georgia so atlanta
makes a lot of sense but what might
not make a lot of sense as kind of this
arts and entertainment dan kathy
um i think it's important to remember
that uh chick-fil-a is a family business
his father founded it um and he and his
brother
inherited chick-fil-a but dan kathy
apparently i
we didn't speak to him for the story he
refused to comment but he's apparently
always been interested in the arts
according to frank patterson who is the
ceo of trilith the studio
dan kathy is an amateur photographer and
phenomenal trumpet player
so apparently dan kathy has this art
side and i think that trellis is really
his
opportunity to put his mark to
differentiate himself from the
chick-fil-a family
in terms of the movie business he kind
of arrived at it by happenstance
in 2009 um that the lifetime show drop
dead diva
was looking for a space to rent outside
atlanta kathy the billionaire had an
airplane hangar
that was sitting empty and decided to
rent it out he was connected to
the producers just through an associate
he sat in on the filming one day and he
was hooked
um he got in touch with a lawyer a
mutual friend
and eventually threw connections got in
touch with pinewood studio
pinewood is a legacy british studio um
it's where james bond a number of james
bonds were filmed but they were looking
for a u.s presence this is around you
know 10 years ago
so kathy who had a ton of money and
pinewood partnered up
in 2019 dan kathy and his fellow
investors bought
pinewood out since then they've really
expanded the footprint of the studio
but they've also come up with big plans
for how to expand it just beyond
production
they set up a 50 million joint venture
and they used
the money to buy land in fayetteville
georgia that's that kind of middle of
nowhere
town around 25 miles south of atlanta
the land itself only cost 10 million
dollars and they spent another
40 million dollars building out sound
stages kathy and his associates
spent as much as 10 million per stage to
make them
the kind of stage that directors should
drool over
direct spending in the film industry in
georgia has increased from 92 million in
2007 to 2.7 billion in 2018.
besides pinewood which became trilith
tyler perry studios and just a number of
other
studios in the atlanta metro area movie
making generates about 9.5 billion in
economic impact for georgia each year
and georgia beat out california as a
production home for big budget
blockbusters
because there's infrastructure built up
in georgia now for a decade
it's really easy um there are places for
talent to stay
there's tech companies that can help
with pre and post-production there's
props there's set um it's really kind of
an all-in-one movie town that that
rivals hollywood today